[Music]
pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florio big stories in the national
football league and the baltimore ravens
peter picked up exactly where they left
off last year in the regular season not
the playoffs regular season another win
now 13 in a row in the regular season a
trashing of the cleveland browns to
atone for their last regular season loss
which was
at home to cleveland week four of last
year
the steelers though get the win on
monday night against the giants can the
steelers rise up and challenge the
ravens this year in that division
well mike
i think
i still think baltimore should be seen
as the
favorite and probably the significant
favorite in that division
because and and look this isn't because
of what we saw in the game it's the
injuries that the steelers have taken
now they probably are going to have to
do some major repair work on that
offensive line they played without the
castro and then obviously you saw the
injuries they suffered and we'll see how
serious they are going forward
but
i
would look at the steelers
and basically say that at least in my
opinion watching that game on monday
what i saw was
bud dupree taking over
to me as the biggest damage causer
on that defense and look i have total
respect for tj what cam hayward how do
you not
but the guy who wrecked that game monday
night
was bud dupree
uh made three or four great plays either
at the line or behind the line
on saquon barkley in the run game
and then obviously in the past game
what's amazing about the play that he
made
you know to deflect the ball to deflect
daniel jones's arm so cam hayward could
come up with the interception on that
third quarter drive mike at the time
that's a six point game
and this is the 19th play of the drive
just imagine you know that a guy can be
as fresh
and seemingly shot out of a cannon the
way bud dupree was on that play so to me
i think dupree
uh right now just adds another element
to a defense that's already dangerous
and so i think the steelers are going to
be a playoff team
but i do think that they're going to
have some trouble keeping ben
roethlisberger upright
but dupri gonna make himself a lot of
money if he keeps playing like he did
last night franchise tag this year 15.8
million 20 raise or the open market next
year
peter and uh you know the steelers may
regret not getting a long-term deal with
him done then again maybe he wouldn't be
as dominant if he wasn't chasing that
long-term deal he has yet to get either
way the steelers chasing the ravens and
they are going to have their work cut
out for them they get together for the
first time week seven in baltimore so
they have some time to get ready but the
ravens were just incredible lamar
jackson
uh mvp form all over again john harbaugh
told me after the game that they've seen
growth from lamar jackson in the passing
game that he played about as well as he
could have possibly played i don't know
where his ceiling is but he's getting
close to it and the reality is peter
he's got 23 total career starts
as he sees more as he plays more he's
going to get better so many of these
great quarterbacks today in the nfl are
early in their careers and they don't
have that breadth of experience and they
haven't seen all these defenses and all
these looks and and they they aren't as
comfortable as they're going to be
they're only going to get better and
that's going to make it harder for the
steelers or anyone else to keep up with
the ravens
i think the one thing about the ravens
that i really like right now is that
they have invested
where they're strong
okay so let's talk about the running
game
the ravens have one of the best running
games in nfl history last year and so
what do they do they take jk dobbins in
the second round he makes that running
game great for the long haul mike
they're not just concerned about this
year i like how eric decosta of the
ravens is always having an eye on the
future
yeah i agree with you completely and
they are going to be a huge factor this
year as will the steelers maybe three
games this year between those two teams
by the time it's all said and done
that's it for pft on yahoo sports we'll
see you next time have a great day
[Applause]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports